[Music]
good god you have done just so amazingly
well and stand up you damn right I have
yes that you have reached you have
reached the level and stand up I have
not even heard of before which is you
have pyrotechnics yeah I do
it's almost it's almost rock-and-roll
--is-- yeah see here's the thing Tony
I'll break down to you like this yeah as
a stand-up comedian you know we're used
to just come out on stage they introduce
you and you walk out normally there's
maybe a song or people clap I said I
need to do something different so what I
did was I went and got fire ya know your
laugh and I'm very serious it's real
it's very real smoke fire lasers see I
saw jay-z and Kanye perform and when
they perform I was like Yoda shows
amazing because they got fire I need to
get some fire you mean I can fire this
show be amazing so throughout my show I
have a bunch of pointless fire like it
is this is the okk the best fire is
pointless no I'm literally I have
nothing to do with my show like after a
joke people laugh and I go get fire
closing yeah let's just show this quick
clip very quickly this is you just
[Applause]
if now sake does max aphid I was gonna
say it looks dangerous that's very
dangerous we don't even have fire
marshals in building yeah it's very
illegal what we're doing Bailey that's
good let's talk about that more on
television I want to ask you about
something else
quite a different experience you've
gotten into movies Navin a lot of
success there you you you you shot a
remake of about last night yes and then
I'm told you had your first sex scene in
this movie hasn't come out yet be of a
first sexy first of all thank you for
dropping that bomb on America cuz they
needed to know ah this is my first sex
scene people and you know is what the
people wanted it is people were curious
and they're gonna get what they've been
asking for you know what I want to take
a second to give a shout-out to my
co-star Regina Hall because I know but
you know a very very funny female man
like you said it's a remake of the
original movie about last night but
Michael Ealy joy Bryant Regina Hall raw
and in Regina you know this was tough
for her because she you know she
couldn't get through a lot of these
takes because for her it was real you
know like if I'm acting I'm acting you
just join the professional when I'm
supposed to dream yeah an actor but
she's like oh I don't want to cut and
I'm like if you have to it's the nature
of the business you know
I don't blame her I definitely don't
blame her I see why she was doing what
she was doing yeah but you know guys
you're gonna see a piece of my but it's
not that I didn't go full but it's just
the top part of my butt crack it's
confusing because it looks like it could
be a roach or my butt got a roach in his
head knows that that's a gene on it